welcome back
[Applause]
for in a minute allow me to introduce
myself for you they call me Madame Bingo
Madame Bingo that's right because I
teamed up with the mobile game Bingo
Blitz and it made me fall in love with
Bingo all over again and our show is
teaming up with them too yeah and Bingo
Blitz is more than a regular bingo game
right Joe I mean I'm obsessed because it
offers this core experience of classic
Bingo but it's also full of features and
surprises and then there's something new
every day like additional power apps and
mini games and events and it's fun it
really is and you can play with friends
and I can get a little competitive when
I play I notice you can and guess what
same take a look at us playing a little
Bingo Blitz the other day
I love playing Bingo Blitz with you I
love seeing you in the game I know you
know what else is Fun the word bingo
bingo yeah it's fun it just feels fun to
say it maybe we should like make bingo
word but we just like interchange it
with other words like oh hey get a load
of the Bingo on that guy Exacta Bingo
Mundo you know what else I love doing uh
facing off against you and Bingo Blitz
I'm gonna kick your bingos bingo bingo
mg whoever gets Bingo first wins
[Music]
man you really bingoed on My Parade
that's the way the Bingo crumbles I'm
not Josie Bingo anymore
hey guys five minutes wait are you
playing Bingo Blitz I love that game but
seriously five minutes okay
you hear that five minutes to bingo
Hasta la Bingo baby go Bingo or go home
you really brought home that Bingo now
how do people play if they're at home
and they want to do this well you go to
the App Store you can also go to Google
Play you download Bingo Blitz did I
mention that it's free free and it's so
much
[Applause]
so much to sleep I'm in
I love you
foreign
[Music]